a Colorado man suspected of killing the
mother of his one-year-old daughter is
due to be arraigned this morning Patrick
Frazee is accused of first-degree murder
and solicitation to commit first-degree
murder
he's being held without bail his fiancee
29 year old Kelsey Bharath vanished on
Thanksgiving Day Niki batiste is at the
Taylor County Courthouse in [ __ ]
Creek near Colorado Springs Nicki what
can you tell us Michele good morning
well patrick Frazee is expected to
appear in court here in just a few hours
to face formal murder charges
even though kelsey bares body has not
been found investigators believe she was
killed in her own home and that Frazee
may not have acted alone police suspect
Patrick Frazee solicited someone's help
in carrying out Kelsey Barriss murder
and have even hinted at the potential
for more arrests that's an absolute
possibility but I'm not going to guess
on that at this point in a court filing
prosecutors say they can't give Frazee a
copy of his own arrest warrant because
it may jeopardize substantial ongoing
investigative efforts and the physical
safety of potential witnesses today the
32 year-old blacksmith will face
criminal charges in the apparent murder
of his 29 year-old fiancee who vanished
on Thanksgiving after going shopping
with the couple's one-year-old daughter
Kaylee Frazee who did not live with
Bharath was the last known person to see
her he never reported her missing or
personally pleaded for her safe return
investigators have been trying to find
Barriss cell phone which pinged almost
600 miles away outside Gooding Idaho
three days after she vanished last
weekend detectives and nearby Twin Falls
executed search warrants but did not say
what evidence was recovered I don't want
to speculate where her body is at this
point on Facebook Barriss family and
friends thank supporters saying this has
been an exhausting and emotional time
for us we are trying hard to put the
pieces back together heal and do what we
can with what we are given we spoke with
Sarah's mother Cheryl
earlier this month does the hope wane at
all are you still confident oh there's
there's occasions I think when I get
tired but at the same time there's a
power greater than I am and everyone
else and we'll figure this out and we'll
find her
Kaley is at the center of a legal battle
between her grandparents a judge granted
Kelsey Baris parents temporary custody
last week but Frazee's mother with whom
he lived also once custody and Anthony
another hearing in that case is
scheduled for Thursday Nikki thank you
can't imagine what that poor family is
going through